the biotech firm moderna therapeutics
announced this morning that the first
eight participants in the first phase of
its kovat 19 vaccine trial developed
some antibodies after just one single
dose now that's a promising sign from
the trial done in collaboration with the
National Institutes of Health moderna
was the first US company to test its
vaccine on humans that was back in March
it's expected to start a second round of
clinical trials as soon as next month
first on CBS this morning the president
of moderna that's dr. Steven Hoke joins
us to discuss dr. hope thank you it's
really good to see you you know they've
got the best and the smartest minds in
the world working on this vaccine and
wor it is that many of them work at your
place so could you explain exactly what
you all discovered in the first trial
sure thank you for having us this
morning pleased to announce the positive
you know phase 1 data which showed that
all subjects who had received two doses
of our vaccine in the first two dose
level cohorts that's at 25 microgram a
low-dose and 100 microgram our majors
had zero converted to develop antibodies
in their blood that bound the virus and
importantly actually when we
characterized eight of those subjects
and said we didn't neutralize the virus
in a viral replication essay it showed
that those same and bodies that those
people had developed actually could
neutralize the virus and prevent its
ability to infect human cells all
together we're very pleased by that
result because it suggests were on the
right path with this vaccine now you
said you started with eight participants
how many participants do you need to
show uh-huh we have something here eight
seems like a small number is that pretty
normal so it was just the neutralization
assay test actually we started with our
colleagues at the NIH we were running
the stage one study 45 subjects across
three days level so there's 15 at
mid dose in the high dose and what we
announced today was actually we have
binding antibody data from the first two
cohorts each of 15 people so it's a
total of 30 people already and so we're
very pleased oh yes all of those people
had cero converted and actually they've
serve converted to levels of antibody in
their blood they're at or above the
levels that somebody who's recovered
from the virus it's called convalescent
Sarah the blood of somebody who's
recovered from the virus have so we've
already exceeded what it takes at least
by that measure now the eight that you
reference before they Elizabeth those
rococo we went to that extra level and
said can we characterize the quality of
that antibody response and show that it
actually would have been protective
against infection immune cells and in
fact all eight out of eight of those did
so we're quite pleased with the breadth
of the immune response so far okay I'm
not a doctor but that does sound very
encouraging so what happens now in Phase
two
so in Phase two our responsibility is to
expand the safety and immunogenicity
database and it's really a primary focus
on safety the phase one that vaccine was
generally safe more tolerated but forty
five people is still a relatively small
number and so we'll be looking across
six hundred people in a phase two study
which will start any day now and that
will be to both confirm that we got the
right idea of the dose where we believe
we're going to be protective immunity as
well as that the safety program
continues to hold up there still seems
to be so much dr. Hogue that we don't
know about this virus so how do you
develop an efficient vaccine when it
doesn't seem like we're quite sure what
we're dealing with yet yeah well one of
the great things that we do know is we
can study what's happening to people who
are recovering from the virus
where are the antibodies and immune
system getting ahold of the virus to
essentially clear the the disease and we
have learned from what's been published
to date in terms of infections that
generally people are getting reinfected
they are when they recover their immune
systems have been able
when you look at that particular
question what we discover is that there
are proteins on the surface the virus
particularly one called the spy protein
and they've all learned a lot about and
that spiked protein antibodies to it are
appear to be protective in many people
who've recovered from the virus and so
the approach we've taken in Medora and
other vaccine innovators and
manufacturers have taken is to try and
express that right protein so that the
immune system can learn to recognize it
and protect against the virus now that
that approach we think has a high
probability of success in the vaccine
context but it still doesn't capture all
of the complexity of the disease to your
point that we see in fact as we see the
virus in natural infection in humans
we're seeing all sorts of surprising
things that the virus can do the good
news is though that despite all that
diversity of things we do believe this
approach of going after the spiked
protein will actually address all of
this disease and hopefully prevent many
of this violence okay we all want the
vaccine but we also want it safe what's
your best guest on when we'll have
something on the market quickly what are
you thinking your time line well well we
we're starting to pay student Lee as we
said today we're starting to face three
by early summer which is just a couple
of months away and our goal is to have a
vaccine available for broad distribution
by year and early next year now the
question of course that's out there is
as we start to build data over time and
if we and other others build data that
shows that the vaccine has a potential
for benefit that it's safe and has a
potential for efficacy then of course
there are circumstances where the
vaccine could be deployed to high-risk
populations earlier under something
called emergency use authorization
really though that's an all right that's
not regime that regulators and
particularly fda optimi
all right but i'm focusing on you said
year and next year thank you dr. Stephen
Hogan good luck